this is absolutely terrible what you're
fired class oh hello there I'm Seth
Rogan and you found me at my animation
imagina tour iam where I'm hard at work
on a new picture called sausage party
but don't take it from me take it from
the star ball picture say hello Frank
hello Frank
oh now Frank here knows a lot of stuff
he knows how to dance yet anything that
it had it out and he knows how to cat
see and then but what Frank doesn't know
might just kill him and everyone he
loves well hey wait what that's right
here's a taste you monsters those were
baby carrots there there are lives ahead
of em don't be so dramatic
Frank it's a comedy now you can check
out sausage Potter yourself in theaters
everywhere August 12th ketchup mustard
Oh sausage isn't baaaack happy
- eh boys hey look at this
with that one yes hey Brenda you and me
I'm so happy the gods got our packages
together because we belong together like
we were made for each other get ready
boy ah feels amazing
oh yes I ain't the first to enter
eternity the pipes the pipes are calling
children so you have learned the
terrible truth I gotta tell everyone
everything we believe is a lot but
they're doing this to us because we
touch tips oh I mean it was fine it's
not like anyone writes home and says oh
god I had the best tip shake what your
momma
Hey I am sorry
I accidentally dropped a few things back
there hey I'm gonna fix you I'm gonna
fix this
ketchup mustard Oh sausage is bun
get up straight boys Hey look at this
with that one yes we're chosen hey
Brenda you and me I'm so happy that
God's put our packages together because
we belong together
like we were made for each other get
ready boy ah feels amazing
oh yes trained the first to enter
eternity the peeps that poops are come
Oh yummy skin she's healing me [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah
their children [ __ ] chattering so you
have learned the terrible truth I gotta
tell everyone no one will believe you I
have to try everyone will die otherwise
no yeah that's a good point
[ __ ] me right Hey
once you see that [ __ ]
it'll [ __ ] you up
good luck have fun
ketchup mustard Oh sausages bonus
camping